hey what is up guys on Cape HD here and
this is the Nexus 9 now I'm just kidding
this is the Nexus 6 box and we're gonna
do a little unboxing it's been a while
since I did just an unboxing video of a
product and getting my very first
hands-on impressions of something so
that's exactly what I'm going to do with
this box now this is something that me
and a lot of people have been waiting a
really long time for and there are some
reviews of it out already and I just
want to kind of get my first sense of
how it feels how it feels in hand and
what I think of it so that me further
ado let's go ahead and get this started
before you leave a thumbs up if you want
to see more unboxing videos like this so
the tops off and this is the white Nexus
6 we're going to go and put this to the
side just because it's an unboxing I
want to see what else is in the package
you get this bright red nexus paper work
a little kit here and this is where
you'll also have your SIM card removal
and your instructions that happen to
have number 6 on it and some other neat
stuff I'm going to put that to the side
and you also get your charger your fast
charger actually and a USB cable so this
is what's going to help you get that
super fast turbo charging we will be
testing this stuff in the full review
I'm going to put this right back in the
box and move to the side because I want
to take a look at the Nexus 6 itself so
this is the phone so it's definitely a
big phone right off the bat that's the
first thing you notice and it might not
be easy to tell with my hands because
you might not have the same size hands
as me but this is definitely larger than
most the other phones are going to see
it does have a 5.9 inch display and a
whole bunch of the other things about it
that are really interesting besides the
fact it's the first phone running
Android 5.0 out the box are going to be
really interesting to take a look at
it's pretty light too although it has
that metal ring around the sides like
the Moto X so it does feel very similar
to that in hand but it is a little bit
lighter than I guess I thought it would
be just by looking at it I'm going to
fire it up but I also want to show it
alongside some other similar devices so
while it's booting here we can see it
alongside the Samsung Galaxy Note 4
which has a 5.7 inch display it's a
little bit taller than the note 4 and
it's a little bit wider than the note 4
of course you get that 5.9 inch display
so it should be a little wider I'm also
going to show it alongside the iPhone 6
plus which has a 5.5 inches
but is nearly as big in fact it's about
as tall as the iPhone six-plus and
looking at the thickness it's a little
bit thicker obviously but it has a much
larger battery so again very similar in
terms of the whole big phone market
another one just for fun since the
review of is coming soon enough the
Droid turbo so the Droid turbo is a
little smaller it's more compact but it
is actually about as thick as the droid
turbo since they're both Motorola phones
but anyway it is on let's go ahead and
do the setup so the setup process should
be pretty easy I'm not expecting too
many complications or anything but right
off the bat the first thing I notice is
the display is really beautiful as it
should be I mean it's a quad HD display
big bright beautiful screen
so one thing I notice is with the setup
process the using two-step
authentication to sign into a Google
account for the first time is much
easier on Android 5.0 I also noted that
in my video about Android 5.0 on the
Nexus 5 so I'll link that below of
course that's a video you should check
out if you're interested in lollipop but
I'll just go ahead and get right into
this also it's going to ask me to
restore from a previous device that I've
used so I have a couple of other Android
devices obviously as you can tell but I
do want to set this up as a new device
and not import anything crazy just get
this started fresh so let's just get
right into Android hopefully will bring
me to my home screen in a second yes I'm
in for Google now and I can give it a
second and we should be right to Android
5.0 lollipop so there it is wallpaper
widgets and all the fun so this is
material design at its finest of course
it should be optimized and shouldn't
really start at all and should work just
fine on this hardware I will be testing
a lot of things for the full review so
basically I want to ask if you guys have
anything specific that you want to see
in the full review video which will be
coming in a couple of weeks when I get
to test and use this phone more leave in
the comments section below here's the
new messaging app it's obviously totally
redesigned versus the old one but you
can still use hangouts of course as a
messaging app if you want but yeah let
me know in the comments what you want to
see you have all these new icons here
you have this whole new user interface
and a whole bunch of new things about
this phone to test out so that's all
what I want to test and you guys are
going to help me make this review
hopefully the most thorough one possible
but so far that's minutes--so quick
unboxing quick first look a very fast
video of the Nexus 6 also leave a thumbs
up if you want to see a nexus 9 unboxing
video or something along those lines
just getting my first impressions of the
device but that has really been super
quick first video let's just go into the
easter egg for kicks since I know that
people want to see the Easter egg and
Android 5.0 so there's a lollipop you a
whole bunch of different colors and
hopefully we'll be able to play this
little East dragon get more than one
point I just want if I get more than one
point out in this video
okay alright I can safely end this video
now that I've gotten more than one point
thank you guys for watching this quick
short video and I'll talk to you guys in
the very next one
lots of videos November got headspace